That terrorist normally means generally
to terrorize a innocent human being. IN
THIS CONTEXT, NO MUSLIM SHOULD EVER be a
terrorist. We Muslims should only
terrorize the antisocial element, the
rapist, the robber, those who create
facad. AND THE QURAN SAYS that in
suryanfal chapter number eight verse
number 60, prepare your state of HORSE
AND TERRORIZE THE HEARTS OF the
antisocial element.
So when I became popular in UK
and when the Labor party lost and the
conservative came to power in 2010,
2009 was the last time I visited UK to
give a talk. I've been to UK several
times. So in 2010 I was supposed to give
many talks in Wem Arena and various
places all packed full. So before I land
because I had a five years visa so I
didn't have to take a new visa. But
before I could land into UK when the
labor party lost and the conservatives
came Terresa May was the home secretary
she says who is the most famous
Muslim preacher in UK. So she asked the
home office and the reply came Dr. Zak
and they said Zakin is supposed to come
after a couple of weeks don't allow him.
I said what business can we stop you all
day we issued him a visa five there's
multiple visa already issued
try she told
the counterterrorism department
that TRY AND FIND SOMETHING WRONG IN HIS
speech in which he's broken the UK law
so we can exclude him we can prevent him
from coming they scanned all my videos
they could not find
anything nothing
in fact in 200 9 the head of the
counterterrorism department Charles far
he sent a person to meet me and he told
me you know Dr. Zak this was when the
labor party was in where the labor party
was ruling Dr. Zakir, we know you're
very popular amongst the Muslims. Can
you help us to guide some Muslims who
have gone astray? I said, I have no
problem. I'm there to help humanity.
I don't mind helping you under two
conditions. That you should not ask me
to do anything which is against the
glorious Quran
or the authentic of the prophet. And I
don't want your money because you know
UK has a big budget to buy Muslims.
They pay money and they buy you over and
they make you things which are against
Islam. So I knew about it. I said as
long as you don't ask me to do anything
against Quran and I have no problem. I
can help you. I don't require money
also. So don't try and attract me. And
we were in coordination. But after about
7 8 months when the government changes
now Teresa May who at that time was home
secretary later on becomes the prime
minister.
She wants to exclude me.
Then she sends the people from UK
counterterrorism department to meet CI
outside. Check with them whether you can
get some proof again. Dr. Zakin
mashallah I'm on the list of CI, FBI, UK
department. Alhamdulillah
I'm on the list of those people
inshallah who will not go to Jenna.
You'll not find them in Jenna. If you
don't follow Quran, you'll meet them in
Janam. So they said we don't have any
proof
yet exclude. They said if you exclude
Dr. Zakai if he goes to court we will
lose I will handle the court. So in 2010
they exclude me. I supposed to go for a
lecture tour. And why I'm telling you
this I'll tell you. They exclude me and
before I could leave my country they
sent official letter through the high
commission to the UK
to tell me to tell me that I'm excluded
for 3 years and they give the reason one
of the reason is Dr. Zakin says every
Muslim should be a terrorist so I'm
giving you the context what they do they
quote out of they don't give the full
sentence that Dr. Dr. Zakin Nank says
you cannot terrorize any innocent human
being. Oh Dr. Zakin Nank says every
mushim terrorist. So he's promoting
terrorism.
So mashallah we hire the best of lawyers
one of my fan. And my lawyers told me
Dr. Zak 99.9% you win the case. They
have no evidence. My friend who funded
who paid a million pounds1 million we
fought the case to the Supreme Court to
the court of appeal and then went to the
European court. He told 95% we lose.
This government they are not just but
yet we'll show them. I was the only
Muslim who went to the Supreme Court up
to H European Court of Justice. We did
the case and my friend was right. We
lost the case but we won the battle. A
PTV we continued. They did not go ahead.
So the strategy